les deux ce contexte de guerre en
ukraine les les bombardements redoubler
en cette fin d'après midi une semaine
après le début de l'invasion la capitale
ne capitule pas mais dans le sud est du
pays les troupes russes pourraient
bientôt réussi réalisé une fonction
stratégique famille au caire
des secouristes évacuent les blessés de
cet immeuble d'habitation jeudi une
frappe russe sur la ville de tchernihiv
au nord de kiev aurait fait au moins 22
morts de source ukrainienne cette nuit
les chars russes ont pris le contrôle de
la ville de carson au sud premières
grandes agglomérations désormais occuper
plus à l'est les bombardements se sont
intensifiés notamment à marioupol ou ici
à kharkhiv le président volodymyr
zelensky s'est adressé à la russie nous
allons reconstruire chaque maison chaque
rue chaque ville et nous disons à la
russie apprenez bien les mots réparation
et contribution vous rembourserait
intégralement ce que vous avez fait
contre notre état contre chaque
ukrainien nous n'oublierons pas ceux qui
sont morts
des pourparlers entre les délégations
ukrainiennes et russes ont débuté cet
après-midi face à la progression russe
au sud et à l'est les ukrainiens demande
l'ouverture de couloirs humanitaires
pour évacuer les civils des zones
assiégées
au septième jour du conflit jean yves le
drian prévient le pire pourrait être à
venir nous sommes rentrés dans une
logique de sièges devant la montée des
concentrations autour de ces villes là
on peut craindre une logique de sièges
saler les rues sont habitués à des
conduites de guerre en logique de sièges
rappelez-vous alep rappelez-vous grosse
ni etc et là ça peut devenir très grave
en attendant l'exode des ukrainiens se
poursuit un million de réfugiés ont
désormais fui le pays selon les nations
unies cet après midi les ministres de
l'intérieur des 27 se sont mis d'accord
l'europe accordera une protection
temporaire à tous les réfugiés ukrainien
et on va faire ensemble bilan de cette
première semaine de guerre évoqué aussi
la stratégie
de vladimir poutine avec mes invités
irina dmitri chine bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'institut national des langues et
civilisations orientales responsable des
études ukrainienne pascale joannin
bonsoir un soir à la direction générale
de la fondation robert schuman on attend
d'une minute à l'autre gérard françois
du mot qui veulent rejoindre vous
assisterez à ce qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon une entrée à vue laetitia casta
éditorialiste politique toujours à mes
côtés
irina dmitri chine 7 jours après
l'entrée des troupes us sur le sol
ukrainien le sol de votre pays
quel bilan vous faites de cette première
semaine puis il ya une dimension
historique que je voudrais vous entendre
nous raconter pour peut-être expliquer
le fait que vous soyez pas surprise par
la résistance du diable oui nous nous
attendions que les ukrainiens se battrai
bec et ongles pour leur terre d'abord
extrêmement attachés à leur terre ils ne
peuvent pas la quitter ensuite la guerre
dure quand même dépit de 2014 et ses
trésors de résistance ont déjà été
manifesté je rappelle que l'aéroport de
donetsk a obtenu presque sept mois et
n'a été n'est tombé qu'en janvier 2015
alors que les combats ont commencé au
printemps 2014 mais surtout ça montre à
quel point les ukrainiens sont un peuple
européen et il faut pas oublier que le
cren faisait partie de l'europe jusqu'au
17e début xviiie siècle lorsqu'elle est
partie du grand duché pour la lituanie
l'ukraine avait le droit de magdeburg
loi le cren avait cette culture d'auto
organisation de ces sites et de ses
alentours démocratique en version
cessions et à cela s'ajoute la culture
kozak donc de cette communauté guerrière
autogéré et dont nous avons eu hier une
magnifique exemple lorsqu'un député
maire d'une des villes à la frontière a
réuni l'ensemble de ses administrés en
leur disant voilà on nous propose de
nous rendre ou bien la ville sert à
bombarder
qu'est ce qu'on fait et les gens
et on va se défendre donc on ne va pas
on va pas partir et cette décision a été
prise si vous voulez à la cam à sion en
fait exactement qu'on faisait les
cosaques ou des 16e et 17e siècles mais
aussi ça correspond à la culture
ukrainienne delà du premier étage cognac
était larousse 2 km neuvième au 12e
siècle cet état qui était puissant et
respecté à nos parce que je rappelle que
les trois filles de iaroslav lesage donc
le prince un des plus importants preuve
il y en a une qui a épousé henri premier
donc en rois capétiens en 1054 sa soeur
était reine de norvège et l'autre soeur
était reine de hongrie et donc à cette
époque là où les peuples se ne se
déplacer pas où les où les mariages
étaient vraiment des alliances
stratégiques voir qu'autant de pays et
la france qui est comme en 2000 km h
chercher l'alliance de cette crème de
cette route montre non seulement
l'importance de ce pays mais aussi le
respect dont nos djs et donc quand on
déroule cette histoire où on comprend
que pourquoi les ukrainiens aujourd'hui
se sentent profondément européen c'est
toujours passionnant d'avoir ce recul
historique et j'avoue mais je pensais
que les cosaques c'était des russes et
vous nous apprenez que maintenant
c'était on est dans la tradition ils me
craignaient mais il ya là aussi aussi
des cosaques russe mais c'étaient les
ukrainiens la grande différence c'est
que les cosaques ukrainiens ont fermé le
former un état et donc si vous voulez
les cosaques n'existe pas l'histoire
russe sans les cosaques peut
parfaitement exister parce que ce n'est
pas un centralisateur est donc tout à
fait alors on revient à cette semaine
qui sera aussi rentrer dans l'histoire
dont on parlera pendant des décennies et
plus pascale joannin votre bilan avouait
ce que
c'est peut-être sur la stratégie de
l'aliment lui dit comment vous
l'apercevez aujourd'hui
mois rétrospectivement ça fait que huit
jours 1 c'est déjà huit jours je puis
dire bonjour je pense qu'il ya au moins
deux erreurs manifestes café le numéro
platine je pense qu'il a sous-estimé ce
qu'était l'identité ukrainienne le
sentiment national ukrainienne et qu'ils
pensaient à tort je pense que les
ukrainiens elle et ne pas résister que
dans une slave ofili ils allaient tous
accueillir les militaires russes en
héros et qu' ils n'allaient pas lever
les armes contre leurs frères russes je
crois que là il a fait une
mais une erreur d'interprétation
phénoménal
la deuxième erreur de vladimir poutine
au delà avoir agressé un état d'autres
qui existent dont il a reconnu les
frontières à kidal donc en violation du
droit international
je crois qu'il a aussi
fait une erreur sur la sur l'europe une
europe il n'aime pas l'europe il n'aime
pas c'est un ennemi c'est ce truc à
l'ouest qui est n'est pas un état alors
moi je suis chef de ce grand état le
plus étendu je connais le chinois
qu'elle plus peuplé de mon côté je
connais le président américain d'alors
il ya le président us treasury florent
le chancelier allemand se lâche décoder
le premier ministre britannique le
premier ministre italien bon les grands
pays vu les autres je ne les connais pas
je leur ai donc c'est un truc mousse et
pas c'est pas c'est pas coordonné c'est
pas un état n'y a pas un chef donc je
vais en faire de la bouche et de de chez
pas quoique cnra et là je pense qu'il a
aussi sous-estimé gravement la capacité
aux bouteilles pour voler leurs mots de
résilience de l'europe de réactions en
tout cas où il a cru que les européens
allait diviser qu' il allait se passe
entendre et résultat on a en effet une
réaction européenne qui est qui montrent
que l'europe dans les moments les plus
difficiles
c'est prendre ses responsabilités c'est
prendre des mesures que ce soit des
sanctions économiques que ça soit des
mesures qui permettent de dire à
monsieur poutine bon ben écoute tu as
décidé de faire la guerre c'est pas bien
on ne fera pas parce que pour des
raisons diverses et variées on ne peut
pas la faire mais par contre tu vas
avoir en effet en face de toi une
réponse qui est peut-être pas dû à un
power mais du soft power mais du soft
power de telle intensité que ben voila
tu vas tu vas comprendre ta douleur est
donc aujourd'hui on a en effet eu un
président russe qui continue de parler
bien entendu à certains de ses
homologues européens qu'il respecte mais
en français en est un parce qu'il faut
essayer de trouver quand même des canaux
pour essayer d'arrêter ça mais en effet
certainement au bien embêté et je pense
qu'il n'avait pas prévu cette intensité
de réaction et alors on danse a en tout
cas dans sa communication officielle ce
qu'il a il a il a pris la parole il ya
quelques minutes la nuit routine il
reste droit dans ses bottes en quelque
sorte pardon de l'expression
l'opération militaire spéciale se
déroule strictement selon le calendrier
strictement selon le plan voilà ce qu'a
dit l'animé routine qui s'est aussi
livré un jeu mais plein de limay
exercice de transparence sur le bilan en
annonçant un nombre de morts 4 5 98
soldats russes tués et 1500 blessés
doit-on faire confiance à vladimir
poutine sur un tueur un tel bilan je ne
sais pas mais c'est pas totalement
neutre sur pour l'opinion russe pas ce
que il faut pas sous-estimer quand même
la capacité de mobilisation de l'opinion
russe et 2 réaction face à aux morts
quoi aux annonces des morts dans deux
expéditions
d'abord ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment un changement de stratégie
avant les russes ne communiquez pas
vraiment le talent fallait pas parler
d'un majeur avec une rigueur toute
militaire livre est juste quelques
quelques grandes déclarations
aujourd'hui poutine a presque calquer ce
que faisait le ski c'est à dire qu'elle
a parlé du patriotisme de la grande
russie des peuples frères à l'intérieur
de la russie a parlé du lion de
l'héroïsme des soldats russes a nommé
quelques quelques morts à parler de ceux
qui se battent courageusement donc pour
moi c'est vraiment un calque de
discours de la façon d'agir de deux vols
des marines qui donc donc il apprend des
leçons et donc ils voient bien qu'il
perd la guerre de communication de
changement de stratégie deuxième chose
la société russe malheureusement des
pieds d'aider plusieurs années les
les les opposants politiques ont été
soit tués soit poussé à l'exil soient
emprisonnés soient réduits au silence
etc et c'est donc la société russe quand
même est extrêmement affaibli et d'autre
part le peuple est abreuvé par la
propagande dépit des années aussi ce qui
fait que les sondages qui ont été fait
juste la veille de
2,7 guère montré que la cité russe
soutenait à des chiffres absolument vous
faramineux la politique de poutine le
fait qu'il faut punir le cren etc on
peut s'interroger dans quelle mesure ces
sondages faits dans un état autoritaire
peuvent être interprétées enfin être
pour être pris au pied de la lettre mais
l'opinion russe avant et dans les
premiers jours de l'intervention était
quand même majoritairement en en phase
avec avec ses dirigeants maintenant vous
avez raison il ya quand même les morts
mais vont-ils arriver là parce qu'on
entend que les cadavres qui sont
beaucoup plus nombreux que ce qu'il dit
sont soit dans les morgues en
biélorussie soit il ya eu des unités des
espèces de crématoriums
camions qui vont brûler ces corps il
n'est pas sûr que c'est qu'on va venir
jusque jusqu'en russie en tout cas il y
aura de nouveau une façon de cacher ces
chiffres en se cachant derrière donc le
secret militaire ce qui est évident
c'est que là aussi les ukrainiens ont
joué une transparence totale en
permettant à ces prisonniers notamment
d'appeler leurs familles en donnant les
noms de ceux qui sont tombés donc tout
cela on peut plus rien cacher
aujourd'hui donc il peut bloquer
certains canaux d'internet maison bien
que les chiffres sont largement
sous-estimés par par la nuit au petit
gérard françois dumont bonsoir merci de
nous avoir rejoints professeur à la
sorbonne économistes géographes et
auteur de géopolitique de l'europe c'est
aux presses universitaires de france on
est sur un premier chapitre plutôt
militaire et stratégique pour pour
démarrer ce ce débat est peut-être sur
le bilan de cette première semaine quel
est le vôtre mais lorsqu'on regarde en
fait la carte des territoires qui
aujourd'hui sont un peu contrôlées par
map l'armée russe on constate quand même
ce sont surtout des territoires qu'ils
soient habités par des ukrainiens
russophone ce qu'il s'agit de
territoires du sud territoire de l'ess
et de territoires du nord sas et
premiers éléments le deuxième élément
basse et la question de kiev donc si on
regarde l'histoire c'est vrai que
souvent on considère celui qui gagne la
capitale politique a gagné la guerre ou
bien est encore au pouvoir on l'a vu en
afghanistan on l'a vu en irak on l'a vu
en syrie ou en fait bachar al-assad
était considéré comme en fait le
dirigeant du pays parce qu'ils
contrôlaient la capitale même s'il ne
contrôlez guerre le reste du pays
donc c'est en ce sens que la bataille de
kiev est un élément important ça reste
un élément stratégique sur les
territoriaux j'ai vu
aujourd'hui de corrélation entre la rue
sophonie et la rue ce film n'est pas
parce que ces gens sont pro russe c'est
l'action que tablait plus in c'est là
dessus que vous avez tant tout à fait
raison parce que ce qui a beaucoup
évolué en ukraine ces dernières années
c'est là que la question religieuse 1
c'est à dire que nous allions une église
orthodoxe qui en fait était qu'ils
reconnaissaient l'autorité du patriarcat
de moscou et ces dernières années il ya
une évolution considérable dans
l'orthodoxie en ukraine avec tout un
ensemble d'église qui ont quitté le
patriarcat de moscou d'abord et qui dans
un second temps ce sont rattachés au
patriarcat de constantinople et ça c'est
un changement qui montre bien
effectivement l'évolution que madame
évoqué oui alors je vais vous laisser
répondre encore mais c'est intéressant
parce qu'on pour l analyse que vient de
faire gérer en fonction du mot quand
même sur les territoires qui sont tombés
on pouvait supposer
que dans certains territoires il y avait
une grille cpta sion je mets plein de
limay de l'offensive russe et qui
expliquerait l'avant c'est plus facile
que dans d'autres territoires où la
population résiste plus vous n'êtes pas
tout à fait d'accord avec cette analyse
là est évident que là
si vous voulez il ya un dégradé en
prennent donc ça ça va plus on va vers
vers l'est plus la population et à
mélanger la sq en ce moment là le
sud-est du pays si mario pas le port de
mariupol tomberont les troupes russes
auront fait la jonction va avoir toute
une bande de territoire qui sera tombée
aux mains des russes là c'est
probablement à leur objectif d'avoir un
couloir terrestre pour aller vers la
crimée de faire de la mer d'azov la mer
interne
c'est quand même elle marie paule est
encore important il ya un très grande
usine sidérurgique amorin paul donc il
ya un vrai intérêt économique après
avoir détruit complètement elle donne
base parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
rien qui fonctionne les mines sont sont
à l'arrêt ou bien ont été inondés les
l'industrie a été démantelée déplacer en
russie ou bien a été bombardé donc ça
devient vraiment des territoires sans ce
qui économiquement et pèse plus rien là
où ils grignotent le nouvel nouveaux
territoires mais c'est aussi les
territoires les plus proches de lui donc
c'est là où il a pu atteindre
les comprend alors on parlait de
communication on va on va évoquer celle
de volodymyr zelensky dans un instant
mais d'abord donc la dernière
intervention de de vladimir poutine en
tout cas un extrait je vous propose
chers camarades je tiens à dire que
l'opération militaire spéciale se
déroule strictement selon le calendrier
selon le plan tous les objectifs fixés
sont atteints avec succès voilà donc
c'est la version sonore de ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure effectivement
c'est intéressant parce que là on est
dans un cadre qui dénote par rapport à
ce mythe ces dernières infos de tension
on avait un prêt l'impression que
l'image était pris au hasard un peu avec
she derrière derrière table là on est
dans une stature plus présidentiel si
j'ose dire vous avez analysé un autre
événement marquant de la journée
laeticia qui était la première
conférence de presse il s'est plié à
l'exercice d'un vol a dit murray en fait
c'était sa deuxième conférence de presse
il en a fait une le lendemain l'invasion
russe vendredi oui il avait prévenu il
lançait un peu un appel au secours il
avait dit il se peut que ce soit la
dernière fois que vous me voyez vivent
bon entre temps on lui a proposé les
services secrets américains à
l'exfiltration il l'a refusée donc les
mirallas qui sait pertinemment quand il
retrouve les journalistes quel costume
il a endossé celui du héros emmanuel
macron dans un tweet a dit qu'il la
melville le visage de l'honneur de la
liberté et de la bravoure et c'est
vraiment ce personnage que volodymyr l1
ce qui joue jeudi ce personnage alors
attention il n'y a pas du tout de
superficialité un an c'est ce mot dans
cette appellation c'est vraiment une
scénarisation en fait qu'il est en train
de jouer dans sa communication il
inscrit parce qu'il sait que ce sont des
codes de notre époque donc il sait qu'en
adoptant l an en intégrant les codes des
réseaux sociaux il touche un public très
large il touche bien sûr son public et
bien sûr le public occidental mais
peut-être des russes qui pourrait via
les réseaux sociaux tomber on ne sait
pas où en est la censure en russie en
tous les cas je il me semble que cette
communication est totalement inédite
alors bien sûr que tout est inédit mais
la façon dont il s'est emparé des
réseaux sociaux ces vidéos il se filme
avec son téléphone portable comme tout à
chacun fait tous les jours et ce film
lui-même envoie des message quasi
quotidiens et on suit c'est un peu
déstabilisant on suit ce chef de guerre
ce président ukrainien qui est traqué il
ya une centaine d'hommes qui sont à ses
trousses pour pour le supprimer donc
c'est vrai que c'est parfois
déstabilisant parce que on se prend à le
suivre comme une fiction or c'est la
réalité est là il a choisi une
conférence de presse est là aussi dans
la forme c'est différent il y à un
pupitre et lui il arrive je sais pas si
on va le voir sur les images il arrive
il choisit de prendre une chaise et de
s'installer face aux journalistes à
hauteur de journalistes et ça change
tout ça alors vous allez me dire c'est
un détail non bien sûr que tous les
détails sont soignés il est à la même
hauteur que les journalistes il est pas
en costume volodymyr anas qui prend la
parole il a ses habits militaires mais
sans décoration sans médaille sekkaki
mais bon ça peut ressembler aussi un
pareil les vêtements comportent chacun
donc si vous voulez c'est vraiment une
décision il me semble de d'être au
niveau du peuple pourquoi parce que il
est l'incarnation du peuple ukrainien
qui l'a élu à la grande majorité 72% des
suffrages bonjour donne la parole dans
un instant mais je voudrais entendre
pascal janin sur sur le ce que heinze
qui a dit l'une des phrases de cette
conférence de presse ea d'ukraine tombe
la russe crise la russie pardon
s'attaquera au reste de l'europe de
l'est jusqu'au mur de berlin il était
très fatigué dans cette conférence de
presse c'est ce qu'il fit envoyer moi je
bon j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises il a
dit il car décès moïse et je suis
fatigué je n'ai pas beaucoup dormi mais
comment vous analysé cette phrase moi je
me suis dit qu'elle était un peu sous le
coup de la fatigue quand même alors oui
pour rejoindre ce que vient de venait de
dire je pense en effet que les européens
et le monde entier a découvert volodymyr
hélas qui butinent tout le monde
connaissait ce qu'il a depuis 22 ans et
mais par contre volodymyr zenasci qui
aurait dit on aurait pu que répondre que
c'était le présente d'ukraine il ya
encore quinze jours donc là il ya eu une
révélation sur
le président qui dans l'adversité
l'agression se révèle utiliser les
outils de communication comme vous une
mine délire et devient l'emblème de la
résistance à l'agresseur russe en
traînant derrière lui un peuple qui peut
être l'avez élu mais le trouvez
peut-être pas encore là ici il a pris
carrément lala tout là tout là toute la
posture de chef et de et de chefs de
guerre voilà oui c'est un héros aux yeux
du monde reste sur ma question la
question de leur valeur sur l'édition
2010 - 0 et si on
sait que tout ce qu'a dit vladimir
poutine pour justifier l'agression c'est
des mensonges éhontés c'est une fausse
cdc cbc c'est faux
l'ukraine est un pays européen vous
l'avez rappelé madame et ça fait
plusieurs années qu'il y à des
mouvements qui existent en ukraine on a
parlé du maïdo voudra parler de la
révolution orange et moi qui connaît ce
pays j'ai vu non pas des drapeaux de
l'otan mais des drapeaux de l'union
européenne ce pays regardent depuis
qu'il est indépendant vers l'ouest il a
été rattaché à union soviétique
il ne veut plus faire partie de cet
ensemble ils estiment que cette sève
l'avenir de ce pays est à l'ouest et
donc ils aiment la démocratie ils aiment
la liberté ce combat qui est celui qu'il
mène aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement le
combat de l'indépendance de l'ukraine
mais aussi d'un modèle de vie de société
qui occidentale libéral avec les
libertés que cela si en effet à partir
du moment où vladimir poutine dit je
veux
un hic il est ce pays qui n'existe pas
qui a à tropisme nazis puisqu'il pour
reprendre le terme tel qu'il a employés
et ce qui est faux en effet on peut se
dire mais est-ce qu en effet une fois
que pour l'instant ça n'est pas le cas
l'ukraine serait tombée est-ce qu'ils
s'arrêtent à l'ukraine ou est-ce qu'il
va chercher les autres endroits où il y
a des troubles à la frontière où on en
est pas loin vous avez parlé de
marioupol mais derrière odessa à la
frontière avec la
la moldavie il ya une région qui
s'appelle la transnistrie qui ont ces
sessions reconnu par personne sauf la
russie qui vous dit que à partir du
moment où il aurait fait tomber
l'ukraine il faut pas aller trop grave
et si bien sûr ils s'arrêtent voilà oui
il va en moldavie et récupère une partie
de ce territoire mais hélas allant même
pas jusqu'à jusqu'où ira alors si on le
voit sur l'europe juste un petit détail
c'est que la différence c'est s'il
commence à agresser un état membre de
l'union européenne
tous les états membres de nuit ou
presque est temps dans le membre de
l'otan ils s'attaqueraient à l'otan etc
vous avez remarqué quand même que dans
les pays du nord qui sont neutres la
schl à la posture aussi est en train de
changer la finlande qui est le pays qui
a le plus de frontière avec la russie
c'est pas c'est pas là la roumanie la
pologne la pologne a une frontière avec
l'ukraine la pays qui est le détaillant
de l'union européenne via la plus grande
frontière c'est là c'est la finlande la
finlande se dit mais attendez moi dans
cette histoire historique j'ai peut-être
en effet un changement de concept à
avoir un solde à neutre alors et la vie
depuis la pause exigeons la stratégie de
lanières poutine est ce que vous pensez
que sa stratégie c'est d'aller aussi
loin on peut même bien même il y est
même aujourd'hui moi je on a entendu ces
deux thèses ya ceux qui disent il veut
faire tomber ce qui ça reste l'objectif
ou alors finalement est si réussi à
garder toute cette bande territoriales
dont on parlait au sud est c'est pas ça
va peut-être ça être ça la négociation
pour garder ses territoires et s'arrêter
là qu'est ce que vous en pensez il ya
deux possibilités soit effectivement il
a une une stratégie russe traditionnel
c'est-à-dire il va considérer que la
russie
historique c'est à la fois la
biélorussie les petits russes comme on
disait autrefois c'est à dire en fait
des ukrainiens et la grande russie et
c'était aussi le discours de
soljenitsyne vous en rappelez et donc il
va considérer que ces trois parties
doivent cohabiter dans un même système
politique et deuxièmement il peut avoir
aussi cette idée en dix ans mais moi
j'ai besoin d'une profondeur stratégie
et c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu annexé
la tribu c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
garder sébastopol
c'est la raison pour laquelle aussi je
voudrais bien aussi que l'ukraine soit
dans le même cas donc ça c'est la
première hypothèse deuxième hypothèse
donc celle qui vient d'être évoqué c'est
à dire est-ce que poutine est prêt à
aller plus loin si va plus loin il sort
automatiquement à l'otan là on est dans
l'article 5 de l'otan et ce qui est très
important à la fois s'il fait cet acte
là comme déjà aujourd'hui dans la
situation actuelle c'est l'importance
des diasporas des pays en question dans
le reste du monde il faut quand même pas
oublier que d'ukraine c'est un pays qui
en 1990 avait plus de 51 millions
d'habitants et aujourd'hui on a environ
43 millions c'est à dire que vous avez à
peu près 5 à 6 millions d'ukrainiens qui
sont dispersés dans un certain nombre de
pays et qui peuvent se mobiliser dans
les pays où il habite pour inciter ces
pays à voir l'attitude qu'ils souhaitent
vis-à-vis de l'agression des russes or
c'est exactement la même chose à
supposer que poutine attaque la pologne
là aussi vous avez des diaspora
polonaise dans le monde entier s'ils
attaquent les pays baltes c'est la même
chose il faut se rappeler quand même que
les pays baltes ont obtenu leur
indépendance grâce à leur combat bien
entendu mais grâce aussi à une
extraordinaire mobilisation des
diasporas bac qui habitait notamment aux
états unis et au canada et au canada et
qui ont été relayées notamment par
ronald reagan donc ça c'est un point
très important donc moi j'ai du mal
quand même à penser qu'il puisse qui qui
pense lui qui failli le faire ça c'est
une chose mais qu'il puisse réellement
avancer je ne crois pas alors je fais
signe la région va se préparer écoute et
hubert védrine mais je voudrais vous
donner la parole là dessus sur la
stratégie de poutine et finalement cette
idée peut-être que sa carte c'est la
partition de l'ukraine qu'est ce que
vous en pensez je pense qu'il va veut
aller plus loin et se demander est ce
que c'est la construction du glacis
soviétique ou de la pyrrhus qu'est-ce
qui est dominant dans ce qui est dans ce
qui le guide mais il faut pas oublier
que ledit mur poutine a que 8 de mur de
berlin chute du bloc soviétique
un petit officier à dresde pour lui
c'est la fin de son monde et
reconstruire ce monde effacer cet
affront c'est je pense un de ces
stratégies un de ses rêves jusqu'où il
pourra aller jusqu'à ce que ne l'arrête
ce qu'est ce qu'on arrête toi voilà et
l'ukraine effectivement un dpe d'un
premier maillon n'oublions pas qu'il ya
aussi la géorgie il y à la biélorussie
qui est presque devenu sous la
domination de de la russie est donc
cette avancée est inquiète hamon a juste
titre les voisins de l'ancien bloc de
l'est et polonais les hongrois les
tchèques et d'ailleurs on l'a déjà
évoqué dans notre première partie de
débat mais c'est l'une des informations
de la journée la moldavie après la
géorgie demande à
10 ans je fais acte officiel de
candidature à l'union ça prendra
beaucoup de temps et ça va se régler
demain est en effet la géorgie et la
moldavie qui ont aussi des territoires
qui ont été repris par par les russes ou
contrôlées par les russes se disent bien
nous aussi on va faire demande puisque
la procédure est tellement long on sait
jamais ça nous permettra via l'aide de
voilà il ya le symbole il ya le symbole
voilà donc ça aussi c'est quelque chose
que l ens qui a fait à trouver le moment
que c'est son nom sur la demo poutine
voulait
on n'est pas du tout imaginé que ça
allait pour
juste en fait avant la france avant
l'élection présidentielle française il y
a les élections en hongrie le 3 avril
viktor orban zhu un quatrième mandat
consécutif
or victoire au ban ça fait 12 ans qui
regardent à l'est et qu'il essaie de
tendre la main à vladimir poutine ils se
trouvent confrontés d'une part des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
ukrainiens qu'il a décidé d'accepter
contrairement à toutes ses diatribes
anti immigration est confronté aussi à
son opinion publique qui est aussi pro
européenne et qui est anti poutine est
donc là il est en train de revenir et
aussi dans sa communication donc voyez
bien que les pays qui sont limitrophes
en tout cas les opinions publiques ont
bien sûr un poids et un rôle à jouer
dans cette bien alors qui peut arrêter
poutine peut-être que c'est de
l'intérieur que ça viendra je vous
propose d'entendre comme co promis
l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères c'était ce matin sur europe1
hubert védrine et émile simon qui va pas
être soutenus ce peuple or il déteste ça
déjà à l'époque de lurçat la fin au
moment de la guerre en afghanistan le
retour des cercueils de soldats tués en
afghanistan
avait un effet très corrosif sur le
régime a donc on se trompe pas en
pensant que les régions pas vraiment
sony sont pas tellement les moyens
puisque les manifestations vont être
empêchés ou ou réprimer mais tout le
monde truc que ça va dans ce sens alors
une information de cette fin d'après
midi le géant pétrolier russe loukoïl
appels à arrêter la guerre en ukraine
via un processus de négociation et des
moyens diplomatiques
c'est quand même gérard françois dumont
une voix discordante ça c'est pas le
bleu c'est le deuxième plus grand groupe
pétrolier russe et pas n'importe quoi
qui prend 7 a saisi cette option c'est
effectivement très important parce que
là
on ne sait pas comment les choses vont
évoluer dans les rapports de force à
l'intérieur de la russie donc en gros
dans la géopolitique interne de la
russie comme on dit c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut toujours garder des
canaux relationnels avec les russes à
tous les niveaux on dirait de boutines
jusqu'au niveau le plus bas moi
personnellement j'étais un peu inquiet
et la suisse prenne des décisions contre
la russie si vous voulez parce que on a
besoin aussi de territoire note qui
peuvent être des lieux de discussions et
dans l'histoire on sait le rôle qu'a eue
la suisse à cet égard et je pense qu'il
faut garder ce genre de possibilités et
donc il faut faire attention aussi
regarder les médiateurs voilà que que
les sanctions ne touchent pas des
personnes qui peuvent être utiles en
fait dans l'évolution des rapports de
force au sein de la russie est-ce que
poutine peut être renversé
je pense qu'on vit clairement à la fin
d'un règne qui peut être long mais qui
peut s'effondrer comme ça d'un coup
c'est évident que les cercueils et tout
cela la
dégringolade économique
ça aura son effet mais qui peut aussi
durer cette population quand même a vécu
dans les vies dans une situation
économique déjà extrêmement difficile
lorsque vous regardez les chiffres de la
russie sur l'accès au gaz à l'eau
potable etc c'est quand même des
chiffres dignes d'un pays de deux tiers
monde assez c'est vraiment pas du tout
un pays qui de la richesse de la russie
parce que les ressources sont tout
simplement détourné au profit des
kleptocrates et des oligarques donc
il ya sans doute la protestation mais il
ya aussi le fait que la propagande
recouvre tout cela et si les gens
croient que ce sont les américains ont
convenu détruire leur a alors image
d'eux dans un pays respecté écran dans
le monde il y aura peut-être aussi de
beaucoup de populations qui
accepteraient ce genre de de privation
donc on n'est pas un accident mais
j'admire poutine ne craint pas le
verdict des urnes n'est absolument pas
sa préoccupation il suffit de museler
tous les tous les médias ce qui est déjà
fait et
déversés par les canaux officiels
cette propagande qui va qui agit quand
même à l'intérieur du pays privé de
toute autre source d'information alors
on pouvait se demander à quoi sert il y
avait aujourd'hui la reprise du deuxième
round de discussions entre des
émissaires russes et des émissaires
ukrainiens
l'information qui nous a été transmise
les quelques minutes en cette fin
d'après midi un accord pour un couloir
humanitaire
pour l'évacuation des civils parce que
ça peut sembler paradoxal ces
discussions c'est à dire que d'un côté
il ya des bombardements et pourtant il
ya des émissaires des deux pays
continuent de oui parce que il faut
comme le hall avait dit il faut toujours
essayer de trouver une solution anticipé
pour l'instant que dans la conflit et sa
oppose en effet la russie d'ukraine vous
avez remarqué que les européens ont
décidé de soutenir militairement
l'armement de d'ukrainiens et même les
allemands ont fait une un virage
conceptuel majeur depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale en livrant eux mêmes des
matériels missiles etc pour venir en
appui aux ukrainiens donc c'est parce
qu'on est dans cette situation que nous
n'avons pas voulu sceller l elle est
liée au fait du président russe c'est
d'essayer de trouver des moyens de
sortir de là de sortir la tête haute
pour les ukrainiens pour les européens
pour la communauté interviennent et
poutine voilà donc il faut pas donc il
ya des coups de téléphone entre le
président français qui dit tu fais des
bêtises mais dur on parle on continue de
parler pour essayer de trouver la façon
d'en sortir parce que la situation en
ukraine
en ukraine est difficile parce qu'ils
sont bombardés la situation en huant en
russie elle est difficile à cause de la
crise parce que les sanctions
économiques qui ont été décidées par les
américains par les canadiens par les
japonais par les européens ça va faire
mal et on voit bien déjà des oligarques
qui commencent à fléchir passé comme
c'est ceux qui sont visés c'est pas la
population russe a on n'est pas comme
l'a redit le présent dans le public on
n'est pas en guerre contre la russie
c'est là aussi que dans guerre contre
l'ukraine mais contre les oligarques on
a une liste de gens nommément des
banques etc pourtant tout cela semblait
avec
l'oligarque avec plaisir parce qu'à qui
méprisant rues sales qui dit lui même
aujourd'hui il faut trouver une solution
parce que quand on va pas pouvoir
continuer à aller dans ce conflit a donc
il faut il faut trouver des moyens alors
suisse européens et internationaux
voilà lancé des discussions elles ont le
mérite d'exister elle le sait elle ne
permettront pas de trouver une solution
peu sata court terme mais mou il vaut
mieux qu'elle continue à pouvoir se
faire pour pouvoir essayer de trouver un
moment donné une solution qui puisse
permettre de mettre un terme à ce
conflit la saisine inno wood s'est pas
anecdotique parce que le président l'a
rappelé hier soir il va y avoir quand
même des conséquences dommageables pour
l'économie française et au sein de
l'économie française va on a une région
qui va avoir des conséquences
dommageables tout particulièrement c'est
la côte d'azur parce que en côte d'azur
la clientèle russe a représentent des
devises significative et là
malheureusement pour eux elle ne vaut
pas arrivés cette année alors on vous
voulez appelés à intervenir sur la
hausse de la suisse au sujet de la côte
d'azur il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
c'est ce qu'on veut être un
continent de valeurs de principes ou est
ce qu'on veut faire des petits
arrangements d'apothicaire je suis je
trouve ça excellent que la suisse
suivent ces sanctions parce qu'il aurait
suffi à ces oligarques de regrouper
d'envoyer l'eau leurs avoirs en or à
monaco en suisse et se moquer éperdument
des sanctions européennes monaco et la
suisse poursuivi l'union
c'est en effet les personnes visées sont
vraiment des personnes qui sont proches
du pouvoir et qui vont en effet avoir
ces sanctions ça va mal très intéressant
de cette discussion parce que c'est
aussi une question d'efficacité cas là
on est sur la stratégie de poutine et la
stratégie les des démocraties pour
l'arrêter est-ce qu'il faut se montrer
très ferme et je n'ai d'écrire ou alors
est-ce qu'il faut ménager des canaux de
discussion et des négociateurs s'inscrit
dans l'histoire effectivement sol-e
suisse appelle toujours considéré
qu'elle devait jouer un rôle pour
ménager des possibilités de discussion
le problème de la neutralité de dresser
très compliqué rappelez vous quand même
la seconde guerre mondiale ou en fait la
suède est restée neutre
ou la norvège rester neutre jusqu'au
moment où hitler l'a envahi c'est la
raison pour laquelle est aujourd'hui
dans le temps parce que si tu les
relèves n'avait pas envahi elle serait
toujours notre aujourd'hui donc on a
besoin aussi de canaux discussion
surtout en plus s'il ya une révolution
de palais à moscou et qu'on a de
nouveaux dirigeants il faut tout
souciait être prêt à négocier avec eux
et trouver un lieu de négociation parce
qu'il est clair que les négociations qui
se font aujourd'hui à la frontière
biélorusse ne peuvent que déboucher que
sur des éléments tout à fait
homéopathiques c'est pas là que les
grandes décisions peuvent être prises à
bord parce qu'il ya uniquement l'ukraine
et la russie et que cette guerre n'est
pas qu'une guerre de la russie contre
les trains ça va beaucoup plus loin que
ça il ya beaucoup d'autres partenaires
géopolitique qui sont concernés par
cette guerre donc ça veut dire que la la
fin de la guerre qui est souhaitable
elle suppose un accord international
auquel participent de très nombreux pays
il faut bien trouver un lieu où ces
personnes peuvent se réunir
rappelez-vous que par exemple même si
cela n'a pas débouché mais la suisse a
très souvent offert son territoire pour
justement des discussions entre des gens
qui n'arrivait pas se mettre d'accord
alors puisqu'on est toujours autant dans
dans ce débat sur
la question des moyens de freiner
l'avancée des armées de poutine
j'aimerais qu'on aborde maintenant le
chapitre des crimes de guerre regarder
cette cette photo on la trouvait sur sur
twitter aujourd'hui c'est ce que
certains soldats russes peuvent voir
c'est à je pense qu'on va on va le
retrouver on va la retrouver cette photo
c'est un panneau de signalisation
voilà où les le nom des villes a été
noircie ça on l'a vu depuis plusieurs
jours pour pour ne pas donner
d'informations aux blindés ou charice
mais alors ce que alors moi je ne suis
pas fan mais en fait ce qu'on voit à la
place c'est c'la et c'est donc la ville
du tribunal pénal international vis de
la justice monde et justice mondiale je
moi je ne sais pas si ça peut avoir un
impact sur des sur dégradé russe je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez alors on a
déjà eu dans le passé refoulé nous des
guerres de gosselies et quand même eu le
tribunal attention le pénal de la haye
donc pour le sait que c'est un des
éléments de rétorsion gars on a parlé
des mesures économiques on a parlé
éventuellement de de mesures
humanitaires
mais il y a 7 ces mesures là et donc ça
veut dire que les crimes ne resteront
pas impunis et si vraiment on est à
basculer dans le crime de guerre qui est
bien
défini on aura en effet des responsables
pas des factotums des responsables qui
seront déférés devant la justice
internationale
mais ça sera
là c'est après qui peut renverser la
lumière poutine à l'intérieur de la
russie une révolution de palais une
révolution peut aller parce que parce
que le palais serait pas content avec
considéré que ces résultats sont pas à
la hauteur évolution
ta position dans le sens de votre de ce
que vous nous avez montré là c'est qu'il
faudrait arrêter de dire kiev oui alors
je vous l'avais dit madame je
voulais et qu'yves le nom alors je
voulais vous donner la parole presque il
nous reste trois minutes conclure là
dessus herrina dmitri chine je rappelle
que vous êtes ukrainienne pourquoi on
devrait plus dire kiev et bien parce que
kiev dérives de la prononciation russes
qui vivent de pension ukrainien depuis
l'indépendance l'ukrainien est la seule
langue d'état et les ukrainiens ont
comme tous les pays qui sortent des
empires commencent par reprendre en main
leur destin ils compris la toponymie il
topographie et donc les ukrainiens
souhaiterait que les européens les
étrangers par respect par reconnaissance
de leur identité adopte le toponyme que
les ukrainiens ont choisi donc cela est
parfaitement logique et bon il sait être
très important aujourd'hui où il ya un
pays qui a agressé le cren guy donc
dénie aux ukrainiens leur identité leur
droit à l'existence donc ce serait
reconnaître ça va certainement arriver
parce qu'il ya déjà un journal le figaro
qui a décidé ration délibérations qui
ont décidé de l'utiliser kif et qui ont
expliqué aux lecteurs donc je pense que
ces relations aient envie depuis
longtemps elle fait tout ce qu elle le
fait déjà sur gars qui faisait déjà pour
karim et kharkiv c'est une ville qui
n'était pas connu
public oui je vous y dire moi si je dis
kharkiv bon bah pour nos téléspectateurs
c'est une ville ukrainienne si je dis
kif ils vont pas savoir que je dis kiev
donc je vais entendre ce que vous ne
dites étape donc je dirais les deux je
dirais la ville de kiev mais qu'on doit
pendant ce qu'yves je vais essayer de
tenir cette règle dans l'est dans les
prochains jours ça me semble peut-être
un peu anecdotique mais mais important
malgré tout je voudrais vous entendre
pour terminer sur je reste dans la
logique de des crimes de guerre c'est
notre dernier chapitre sur l'état
d'esprit des soldats russes est ce que
je ne sais pas si l'un de vous peut
répondre à cette question parce que c
est évidemment très compliqué est ce qu
on a des retours sur ce que peut être
l'état d'esprit des soldats russes je
vous remets la dentelle joseph leur tour
cessé quand même le discours de poutine
de cet après midi où manifestement il a
fait quand même un discours si j'ai bien
compris un peu compassionnel c'est à
dire qu' il ait quand même lieu quand on
fait comprendre quand même que le nombre
de morts que représente cette guerre le
nombre de blessés ça commence à soucy
une partie sa population puisque si j'ai
bien compris il a quand même annoncé
qu'il allait défrayer les familles enfin
ça remplace pas un enfant qui meurt à la
guerre bien entendu mais enfin il vient
de créer une assurance décès il promet
de soigner les blessés donc
manifestement doit y avoir quand même un
certain mécontentement devant
l'importance des morts et des blessés
américain aujourd'hui ont annoncé la
déliquescence donc le moral qui se
dégradent auprès des militaires russes
n'oublions pas que ça fait un mois
qu'ils étaient stationnés quelque part
donc en dehors de leurs de leur maison
aux frontières de l'ukraine est le
facteur fondamental on n'a pas la même
rage de combat quand on défend sa patrie
quand on est agressée quand on agresse
et ça c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
fondamental et que de petits n'a pas
appris un tout dernier mot rapide à un
tout dernier mot c'est simplement en
effet je pense qu'il ya désarroi delà de
la russie qui pensait pas avoir ce
resistance on a vu des photos de jeunes
soldats qui ont été montrés par qui
était vraiment pas un peu aguerris etc
on s'aperçoit donc maintenant que on est
facile quand même dans un temps au delà
de la compassion l on est quand même
temps de rentrer plus dur alors il ya
cette fameuse groupe wagner qui est là
pour essayer de dégommer
des menaces qui c'est l'objectif qui
doivent avoir et puis on a quand même
nous qui avait un peu d'histoire on a en
effet oui on en arrive là dessus c'est
les tchétchènes appelés en renfort pour
le combat de rue
allergique aux gardois de voir venir
aider à capturer l'ukraine géopolitique
forcément de l'histoire terrible je dois
finir géopolitique de l'europe ces
petites de votre livre merci encore
d'avoir participé à ce débat merci à
toutes les équipes de public sénat ici
en régie des équipes techniques les
équipes de la rédaction de la
programmation voilà c'était une semaine